hi everyone thanks for being here
so
let me let me start so
my name is antoine i'm french i live in
paris and i work at cicar
it's a consulting firm we do
ai for our clients
and
i worked there for
like
four years ago and i am a
head of data science there
so at
the official job title for
for tech is a data scientist but
actually in my mind i think we are more
like
machine learning engineers because what
we do in for our clients it's in between
data science and
classical software engineering
we do
we we conceive models we train uh we do
machine learning and we also put it in
production
build monitoring systems and so on
so um
since it's uh
it's software engineering
do not forget to rely on
best practices and best
best tools
on the other hand machine learning
engineering it's it's a lot more than
just regular software engineering
here you can see in the in the figure
extracted from hidden technical bets in
machine learning systems it's a famous
paper in
rips
so the the code it's a small black box
and you have many systems around
to to
to have a ai project functioning
so
um
the the reasons the main reasons why
software why machine learning is
different from software engineering is
that
you you need to track the data not only
the code
so you need to track the data and to
version the data
and
machine learning it's an exploratory
work it's not linear like regular
software engineering you have to try and
test
and try again and test again
and you need
solid tools for an investigation like
once the model is trained you want to
touch it to fill it
and see how it works
so
let me talk about
what what is in a ml experiment tracking
system
in every machine learning project you
have this
loop
where
at the beginning you collect data and
you you you define a model
then you train it then you evaluate it
and at the end you you have a feedback
loop because you learn something and you
modify something
you modify either the code or the data
so
when you run experiments
you you want a tracking system to be
able to to log the experiment metadata
like
which code did you use which hyper
parameters did you use
you want to be able to compare
experiments
you
when you
[Music]
run a
ai project in the long term you
you end up with lots of experiments
so you want to organize them in a nice
way so that it's easy to search them
reproducibility is very important
because
once something is working you want to
reproduce in order to be able to iterate
over it
and finally we work as teams so
collaboration is a is very important
and
there is there exists many
platform or tools that do experiment
tracking and i'm not going to talk about
them today
zika we used a lot of ml flow
and we also have a poliaxon
running on kubernetes and premise
but i will not talk about this today
instead
i will show you another approach which
is building an entire
experiment tracking systems
with smaller bricks which are dvc and
streamlit
because it will allow
a lot more flexibility and customization
so
let's start doing
machine learning
for the purpose of this talk i
choose a
simple example so i will train a model
to classify
images of cats and dogs
it's like a one-on-one machine learning
for computer vision
and so the goal is to have a model that
should predict given an image
whether it's a cat or a dog
a few words about the dataset and it's
available in a tensorflow dataset it's
3000 images
and here you have some some examples of
cats of dog from the data set
so
here you can see the training pipeline
so to to build my model i will uh
i will execute this pipeline so first i
need to download the data to train the
model
then i
need to split because in tensorflow you
only have a train on test splits you
don't have a validation splits so i
split the
the train into train and val
splits
once i did that i can train a model and
i get a
trained model and at the end i evaluate
this model against the test set
so i will go very quickly on the on the
on the scripts
so to download the dataset i just run
command line
commands download the data set and zip
it and put it in the in the right place
let me show you quickly the the training
script
so it's
just adapted from the term software
tutorial so
nothing fancy in here
what i do basically is that i import
parameters
then i load the train data set on the
validation data set
i define
a model it's a neural network based on a
backbone which is a
a parameter it can be a mobile net or
resnet whatever
and i defense defined some callbacks
and here it goes
i train the model in here
and
you see here the the backbone it's
it's frozen
here i unfold the backbone and i train
it again
so okay now that i have those
four scripts i want to execute this
training pipeline
to do this i need to go in four steps
so first first i need to set up my
experiment
so define the the parameter i want to
use eventually modify the code or the
data
then
i need to run the pipeline so so far i
have no tool so i need to run the the
command manually in the right order
so this is i'm not very happy with that
[Music]
then i need to save the results uh the
the scripts i'll just show you there's a
produce uh data that
it downloads the data set at the end
when the model is trained i have the the
neural network weights
and the metric files so i have to save
it somewhere either
on my laptop an s3 bucket or somewhere
and finally i need to have a record of
the experiment
which parameter did i use which code and
so on
so usually when you have no tool you you
put it somewhere in some spreadsheet
so to improve this
you could use dvc
how many people here know dvc
okay
so
dvc
it's a very popular um tool to um
to version data
so the
the the most basic feature is that it
will re it will replace large files that
you don't want to track with git
by a small metadata file
and
that you can track with with kit
and it also has
[Music]
it also supports a remote storage so
when you
[Music]
when you decide to track a
large file with dvc it's stored
in the local dvc cache folder
and you can run a dvc push pull
to
to sync with remote data storage
if you are familiar with
git api it's very similar
like in git you have a git add git
commit in dvc you have dvc add dvc
commit dvc checkout it's
basically the same api
so
this is nice but so far it's not
more than
older tools like git large file system
that do pretty much the same
um
what is very interesting with dvc is
that it allows to to build a repo
reproducible pipelines
so it's the next step so here is a
simple example i have a pipeline with
two stage let's say stage one it
consumes fail file a and b and produce
file d
and i have another stage that will
produce file e
so i define i'd simply define the
pipeline with this ml file here
all i need to provide for each stage is
the
the command to execute
it it can be python but it can be
anything actually
and i have to declare the dependencies
and the output file
and whenever i want to run the pipeline
i simply run dvc repro
gcml file and it will resolve the dags
to know
the order of
in which order it should execute the
stage
it will
run the pipeline so execute the stage it
will track all the data inputs on output
and there is also a mechanism for
caching stages
like if
say stage 2 the dependencies didn't
change it will automatically restore the
output
which speeds up a little bit the
pipeline execution
so
let's go back to my training pipeline
now i have two more files so the first
one is the
pipeline
definition
so i have a four stage
one for each green box here
so for instance the train script i just
run the python trend dot py
i have the dependency so the script
itself the trend that i said the data
set
and at the end it produced
the model best weights the model itself
and
transfer board files
okay
so now that i have
the dvc pipeline
let's go back again to
running an experiment
so
to run the pipeline now it's much
simpler i simply have to run dvcrepro
dvc.ml
save the results
it's also done because
dvc will
automatically save the all the data
produced by your pipeline and you can
save it to the remote storage by running
dvc push
and
for the last part put the experiment in
the right place we are
in a we are it's better than before
because you can access the the
the
experiment in the commit history but
still it's not very practical
you don't want to search experiment by
running git log
so it's time to
[Music]
to to come again to differences between
software engineering and data science
data science
classical software engineering it's
mostly linear workflow
even if you have branches in your
projects when as individual you you code
you do one commit after
you work linearly
and data science it's
not linear because usually what you do
is you
modify some code then you run not only
one experiment but usually many
experiments because you want to
do say a grid search on some parameter
so you from one commit you will have
a
several experiments and sometimes you
from an experiment you you you may want
to to refine it by running it again so
it's not linear
in dvc they have this feature
dvc experiment that allows you to to
track this non-linear workflow
and
basically it relies on a git custom
reference
and
a git reference
you
if you are familiar with git you
manipulate them
every day
the the git reference you know are
branches on tax basically a reference
it's just a commit name
it's just a pointer to a commit
and
dvc experiment
it will create a new kind of
git reference called
experiment
and
it will like this track every experiment
you run
in a non-linear way
so
let's talk about the api
instead of running dvc
x
dvc repro you just run dvcx run
what you will do is that it will
for you edit the parameter.tml file
so you can provide
[Music]
the hyper parameters from the command
line
it will run the pipeline like a regular
dvc repro
and at the end it will it will
automatically create a commit and track
it with a git custom reference
so
how do i see the
experiment tyron
so
let me
run this
it's not this
here i will get the the list of
experiments available in my
git repository so here you see i have a
commit hash which is the parent
of this
nine
experiment if i want details about
those experiments i can
sorry
so
to get the detail of the this experiment
because here i don't have any
information
i use dvcx show and i enter the the
git commit
parents
so here you see
i got the nine experiments and i have a
lot of
columns so let's say i want to only see
a few ones
like the accuracy and some training
parameters i can filter the the column
like that
and in the end i end up with an
experimentable that
which is pretty fine
so in my nan experiment i see the
accuracy is close to
it's pretty good it's 96
um because the problem is pretty easy
actually
and what changes between the the
experiment is the train seed and the
the the depth of the fine-tuning
so
if we get back to the
to running an experiment what we can see
is that
for the three first steps we are pretty
much the same but for the
organizing your experiments we are a
little bit better
thanks to the experiment table you can
display running dvc exp show
so let's take a step back here and see
what we got regarding the ml experiment
tracking system thanks to dvc
we we are very
we are very strong with logging
experiment
data and reproducibility
because you can check out any commit
from any experiments and run dvc repro
and it will run just as before
regarding
organizing and comparing experiments
i can do it but from the command line
which is
which is fine but
there is a room for improvement
like
how do we build
a ui to visualize experiment
so that's where i am introduced
streamlets
so
[Music]
streamlets it's a it's a python library
to to build the data apps
so you you don't have to to know how to
to develop web applications you only
code in streamlit
and
actually the the the the the slides that
i
i'm just showing you are written in
streamlit
and um
it's uh
it's about to become so the most popular
library for building a dashboard
in python
and so on i will go for a quick demo of
the the
streamlit api
so you you just install it with pip and
you have
a lot of
function in the swimlet api that allows
you to
to display whatever you want so let's
say i want to display latex formula
i can do it like this and
what is really important because so far
a display data you can do it in regular
jupiter notebooks
what you can
build easily with
streamlit is interaction
so let's say
i want to have a select box like this
so here you see i declare a select box
with two options cats or dogs
and i store the result in this variable
that i just
print in here
so it renders this
selector
and whenever i change the value here it
gets updated in here
and you have more advanced
more advanced inputs like for instance
i could use my camera
to get a picture
so you see here
i use camera input and
i get
the image here and if there is an image
i just
show it in here
so it's an empire i can do whatever i
want with it
so
let's get back to
the cats on dogs problem
so
[Music]
my neural network but
it's it's a bare output it's a it's a
probability of being a cat or a dog and
if i look at the raw prediction on the
test set
it's here so you see here i
read the prediction using pandas
and i
display the data frame we streamlined in
this line this will produce
this table
so you see the prediction it's the
probability of
being a dog i have the true level and
the predicted level the predicted level
by default it's computed with a
50 threshold
but
let's say i want to modify this
threshold for instance the first line
it's a cat
but the prediction it's close to 250. so
let's say i move the slider
below 43
and then
as you can see
the predicted risk threshold it changes
from cats to dogs
cats dogs and i get the accuracy updated
in real time
and all this the the right part of
my slide
is produced by this code which is very
very simple to do
you could display image let's say i want
to to see the
images for which the model is not sure
so close to 50 50.
so with a slider with two entries i can
get a min and max threshold
and
here i simply
filter my data frame to get only the
images
whose confidence is
below those two thresholds and i use
st.image
to plot the images
and
[Music]
for for instance for those two
thresholds i have seven
unsure predictions
and this one is pretty interesting
because there is a cat on a dog on the
same image so
it looks like the model is working fine
fine actually
and
finally what i could do also is to
directly run the model in my
in my
app
so to do that
i simply need to to load the model using
tensorflow
and i
i
get an image from a file uploader and
get it to the model and print the
printing print the print the output
prediction we stream it
so let's try it
this cute cat for instance
okay so it's working fine because
it's pretty sure it's a cut
and what is interesting in here is that
you can try the model with
whatever you want for example let's try
edge cases
let's try a lion
and you see that it's the model is
pretty confident the lion is a dog
so it's it's very easy to to build a ui
to experiment the model to try it to
you can do a lot of things with with
this
so what's next
and
the streamlets app i just show you it's
it shows you the model that is in my
current workspace
and
i cannot
what i would like to do is to
to see the model from other past
experiments
so actually it's like i have two
dimensions streamlit it allows me to to
build a
very expressive data visualization uh
try the model or an interference and so
on
streamlit it's very good at
tracking experiment data and now i want
to combine them
to build a
[Music]
ui that allows me to explore experiments
so how do we do that
the first thing to to do this is to
retrieve experiments
in python
so to do this i will use the
the dvc python api which is very similar
to git's python api
so first i initialize a repo
from my current directory then i can get
all
experiment commits
running this command it's like a dvcx
list that i just showed you before
but in python
so it gets me
a json
this is
the commit parent and this is the
experiment names
once i have this
i can get the
experiment detail
by running this
experiments that show it's similar to
dvcx show command online
but it's in python and you see here i
have a lot of information coming out
so for instance
here
it's an experiment i have all the
parameters
which file was used which parameters
batch size image size and so on
i have the ashes of all dependencies
i have the hashes of all outputs
and i have the metric here and i have
the experiment name
so having this
it's very easy now to to build
a ui for a table of experiments
so this is the
wall code so
first i retrieve experiments metadata
just like i showed you before
then i flatten it
this way so that i can wrap it into a
data frame
and in the end i use trimnit to do the
rendering
and what i get with that is that i have
this table here it's similar to what we
got with dvc app show
except that it's in streamlit
and
i can i can do plot like
here i
plot a bar chart
of all the accuracies
of all experiments
and actually you can do whatever you
want
at this stage for instance here i want
to plot the accuracy versus the level of
fine tuning
so i use plotly because with streamlets
you you can plot graphs with plotly with
vega whatever framework you're familiar
with it's very easy to plug it into into
swimlet and
here it goes so
you have the accuracy against the level
of fine tuning
and as you can see
there is no correlation it seems like
it's a random seed that defines
the level of accuracy of the model
and
what can we do after that
and
now that i have the table of experiments
i have all the details
of the
the experiment logs
but what i would like to do is to to
actually
load the files from this experiment
let's say i want to
run and to try the model from a past
experiment i need to to retrieve the
model files
from that commit
to do that you can use a dvc python api
which provide an open function that is
similar to the regular python open
function
except that
it's like it's open to a new dimension
because you can pass
you see here the the
commit hash
and it will read the the file from any
commits
in particular it could be
an experiment commit that is not tracked
by a
git branch
so here i just i've
i just opened the prediction that tv
file and ready tris upon us
and once
now that i have this function i need to
feed it with
commit
commit ashes
so i just
get the experiment that i'll just type
just as before and i build the
i build options for a select box that
looks like this so here i have the
experiment commit ash and the experiment
name
and what i when when i have this
it becomes pretty easy to build
something like that
so let's say i want to to build a
an app to compare two models
so i simply we extremely put two
selector
for selecting experiments
and
so the two selectors are here and here
once i i have selected a commit hash i
simply load the predictions with the
function using dvc.open
function
and i merge them in a single data frame
and i can do whatever i want
so for instance i could i can get the
predictions
on which both models disagree
and
[Music]
and display those images in the in the
streamlit app
so let's try it
so it looks like these two experiments
agree
okay
so here it goes
i will
hide this column
so
these two experiments you see that the
model disagree on two images
and
each of them is right
in
one case
and here you have the image
where the model disagrees
so
let's let's take a step back here
and see what we got
now we have a
[Music]
all we need to to build
an experiment tracking system
so um
to compare experiments sorting them i
can build a streamlit app to
to organize my experiments the the
demonstration i i just show you it's
pretty basic but in streamlight you can
go
you can customize as much as you want
and you can compare experiments you can
have the experiment table and you have
since its code you can commit the
streamlight application in your
project repository so it's a common
interface for the wall
team
it goes through
code review and so on
so
[Music]
let's take let's talk about a bit about
the advantage the drawbacks of this
approach
and the main advantage is that you can
do whatever you want with the ui
here i just show you example of
images but you you can have an ai
project of
where you deal with video audio
text
all of them
you can do
pretty much what you want in streamlit
and you have a lot of
primitive
function
in streamlight and you also have some
communities that develop
a lot of custom components
you can even develop your own component
in
javascript if you want
um
also another advantage it's it's very
easy to set up you don't need uh for
instance if you if you want to deploy a
ml flow you need to have a server you
need to
to run the infrastructure you need to to
deploy it here
in five minutes you are set up you can
initialize dvc and have your first
3 dashboard
on the other hand
[Music]
dvc and streamlets are
quite recent
technologies
so we we cannot predict their future
they are
in
they are very promising technologies
but
still
it's it's a very recent technology
and
[Music]
the the way of developing the this ui
for tracking experiments it may be hard
to maintain
because it's the team who
who develop it so
you have to
to code review it you have to deal with
technical debt
and
you also have to to handle retail
compatibility because
during the life cycle of a project the
pipeline they may change
a
lot
and
when you
you you go deeper in customization
maybe what was working before is not
working now so you have to
fix
continuously the the web ui
you don't have this problem if you use a
more classical tracking experiment
system
and
what i didn't show you today is
how to deploy streamlet app so you can
just dockerize what i've showed you
and
something which is not trivial is
how to handle with
dvc in docker because it's very easy to
to decolorize a stimulate application
what is not easy here is that
the the ui it requires
a dvc repository to
be able to search experiments
so usually when you deploy code you only
the products occur you do not deploy the
the git repo with it so you have to
dockerize this as well
and i didn't talk about the
infrastructure
which is outside the scope of
ml experiment tracking systems
and
what you could do see is
have an integration with ci cds
actually iterative that ai who is
developing dvc's a proposed cml
that allows you to say
trigger
the training of a model
when you push some code on github
so
that's it for me
[Music]
yeah thank you very much that was a very
very interesting talk i guess everyone
was really impressed with the layout of
your presentation
so
we have many questions we probably won't
be able to go through all of them
uh but yeah let us collect the most kind
of vote ones
so the first question is what's your
experience with using dvc for storing
trained models maybe compared to ml flow
do they work well together
i didn't try dvc and ml flow at the same
time but i know
i have colleagues that did that
and
i know it's feasible but it's not that
easy
because
ml flow and dvc there are
there is a intersection between what the
two tools
do
they both tracks
model parameters and so on so it's not
easy to define who is doing what
but i know it's it's visible
all right i think the second one you
comment a little bit but maybe you can
expand on that so can you include
execution of dvc pipelines into a common
ci cd setups in order to run pipelines
automatically with every new push
yeah
you can use html
and
it's it's a wrapping it's a detail
actions that allows you to
trigger whatever pipeline you want uh
when you
push on some uh branches on github
it's very easy to set up life in five
minutes you can say
whenever i i merge on the master branch
it triggers a training on a ec2 instance
and aws
all right the next question is how well
does dvc handle gtb gdpr compliance can
you delete experiments or raw data from
its history
[Music]
i have no idea how to answer this one
all right sorry
alright so a
one
a question that you already maybe
answered during the presentation is
what's the name of the neet presentation
tool
i'm sorry what's the name of the
presentation tool that you like how did
you write the presentation oh yeah um i
use a semi component called the
streamlightbook
and it allows me to
to have this
left panel here with sub sections
so actually the main chapter selection
it's a regular streamlet select box
but what you got in here
it's from a streamlit book
so you just run a pip install simulate
book and you have a
very
nice and simple simple interface
and each slide it's actually a
separate python
file
it's it's a bit overkill to to to slide
this way
but
i would say it's not
but it's it's really nice because
actually i did that because it was much
easier to to show the the result of
streamlined codes directly in the slides
we start sweeping from slides to
to a
web browser all right maybe a related
question is if you could
if you're planning to share the code of
the generation sure okay
all right the next question is what
what's the advantage compared to
solutions like neptune ai
um
i
i actually it's maybe the one i know the
uh i don't i never tried a neptune ai
[Music]
my my understanding is that it's a
it's a service when you where you have a
patent api to log parameters and
artifacts like data but it's completely
separated from the the git history
so the main advantage of dvc is that
it allows you to to really
link experiments with git commits and
it's not logging it's a it's a real link
like if i want to retrieve my experiment
i just check out any commits
and run dvc pool and i get all the files
on the code and so on
uh
whenever you use neptune ai or ml flow
or phone it's a logging system so it's
outside the code so of course you can
log the commit ash and so on but
let's say you you do a
git rebase and the commit hash
is changed
you you lose
the commit reference
it's not possible with
dvc
all right
another question is how does dvc
experiments tracking work if you have
multiple data scientists working at the
same repo
that's a good question
[Music]
it's just lad it's it's actually it's
just like a code review
when you have conflicts you have to
resolve them
and usually it's not that hard it's
simpler than
resolving code conflict you can because
when you have code conflicts you have to
look in the file and see okay you modify
this line and modify this line how do i
merge this
and when you run experiment
most conflict resolution it just
overwrites the the files that
track the hashes of the output file
so it's
in practice
it's
fairly easy
all right so there's another questions
about the infrastructure so how do you
integrate dvc into infrastructure is
there a kubernetes scheduler or similar
and
dvc do not provide a
to my knowledge a tool to do that except
cml
so
you have to do this outside
and the most basic way of doing it is
just a ssh to a server and run a
dvc export
and what you could do is automatically
this a little bit but
actually it's maybe at car we use a lot
of dvcm framelits and maybe this is what
we should improve
all right so i have no
proper solution to do this all right
there are many questions which are tied
so let me
uh yeah finalize with the with with the
with a question about yeah selecting the
tool for the visualization so are they
like advantage or disadvantage or let's
say what's your take on extremely versus
dash
i used dash
like
two or three years ago
if
dash it
is really nice
but i think you you need to to be more
familiar with web development
uh
python streamlet what is the
real strength of streamlit is that
it really makes you feel like you are
coding a python script
like
you have no callbacks you have no
components it's a really uh pythonic way
of developing a web app it makes you
believe you are coding a python
python script but you are not you are
building a web app actually
and when you
when you develop a platform you
you you have to to
to be familiar with some concept of web
development
like callbacks components and
the interaction of components it's a
it's a bit trickier
all right thanks so i think that's all
for the questions but i guess you can
reach and find a in the conference so
let's thanks antoine again for this
great presentation thank you